[Musica]
salve a tutti sono felice di essere qui
perché oggi posso raccontarvi una storia
per dimostrarvi una cosa che a me è
molto a cuore
per me tutti i giovani dovrebbero sapere
cosa significa imprenditorialità e per
me tutti i giovani devono fare propria
questa parola qui perché una parola
importantissima inizio con raccontarvi
un po la mia storia
cosi capiremo insieme perché il perché
di questo pensiero
io ho avuto la mia prima esperienza
imprenditoriale di team management se
così lo possiamo chiamare quando avevo 7
anni andavo a scuola non mi piaceva
studiare quindi decisi di tornare a casa
e convincere le mie nonne le mie zie a
partecipare a questa organizzazione che
volevo mettere su che svolgeva i compiti
per casa per me
sostanzialmente io tornavo da scuola
avevo già tutto organizzato andavo della
mia organizzazione dicevo guardate qua
ci sono i compiti per favore gli
svolgete entro pomeriggio è chiaro però
vi prego di inserire degli errori perché
i professori o i maestri allora ero la
scuola elementare potrebbero accorgersi
che c'è qualcosa che non va
e fu così che per qualche mese andò
avanti poi mia madre mi scoprire di cosa
stai facendo
ok scusami andò avanti provai a studiare
ma non era il mio forte o comunque non
mi piaceva arrivato alle superiori
decisi di andare allo scientifico per
seguire i miei compagni perché io volevo
stare con loro avevo la mia comfort zone
come si suol dire arrivo le superiori al
liceo scientifico il secondo anno mi
faccio bocciare mi faccio bocciare
perché non mi piaceva l'ambiente troppo
serio allora mi trasferisco
all'industriale dove iniziò a studiare
informatica e lì capii che probabilmente
poteva essere la mia strada
probabilmente attenzione perché poi
capiremo il perché studio informatica mi
piace faccio anche qualcosa al di fuori
del programma inizia a programmare
android
allora erano appena uscite le
piattaforme android e quindi inizia a
programmare android fece qualche piccola
applicazione incomincia a totalizzare un
po di download fino al punto che è le
mie up in un mese circa totalizzarono
circa 50.000 download
ap di un altissimo livello di stupidità
tra l'altro quello che facevo io ogni
giorno era stare davanti
il play store e capire quale poteva
essere la necessità che in quel momento
gli utenti potevano avere e uscirono
diverse app la più importante
probabilmente si chiamava youtube
downloader perché mi accorsi che c'era
questa necessità
già dal nome si capisce cosa fa
l'applicazione allora pubblico youtube
downloader negli store e di due
settimane totalizza un milione e mezzo
di scaricamenti io ho 19 anni avevo
creato l'app più scaricata al mondo
partecipo a un contest internazionale di
una grande multinazionale e vinco nelle
ultime due settimane di questo contest
100.000 dollari
non vi lascio immaginare la mia felicità
a 19 anni essere il primo al mondo
guadagnare tanti soldi al giorno ed in
più
vincere un premio di una grossissima
multinazionale di 100mila dollari per me
fu il massimo per me e per i giornali
che incominceranno a parlare molto di
questo i media nazionali ed
internazionali parlavano tanto di
youtube downloader è di questa di questo
genio del web il genio delle app
io vengo da un paesino di 7 mila
abitanti che si chiama valguarnera
caropepe e della sicilia
amy nominarono come lo steve jobs di di
carrapipi perché così che si chiama il
paese mi lascio immaginare i miei amici
gli sfottò che partivano però per me fu
veramente il massimo perché tutti
volevano sapere di me
dalle otto di mattina alle dieci di sera
incessantemente il telefono squillava
casa rispondeva mia madre rispondevo io
facevo tante interviste radio
televisioni ad un certo punto però
qualcosa inizia ad andare storto dei
blog iniziarono a sollevare dei dubbi
riguardo la legalità di questa
applicazione
ma scusa tu puoi scaricare da youtube ma
forse sì o forse no e allora lì in
comincia ad avere paura perché forse
l'imprudenza no l'essere troppo piccoli
mi avevano portato a non riflettere
tanto da dei blog si passò dei grandi
giornali delle radio e delle televisioni
la paura cresceva io ero disperato
accade che un giorno io guadagnavo
tramite i banner inseriti nelle
applicazioni gratuite
questi guadagni erano elevatissimi ed un
giorno mi tagliano tutti i guadagni per
farvi capire con quel guadagno avrei
potuto acquistare una macchina di medio
livello
gli avevo guadagnati in una settimana e
in una settimana me li hanno tagliati
via io ero disperatissimo non sapevo
cosa fare
la prima cosa che pensai e basta sono
stufo non ne voglio sapere più ho paura
voglio cessare di essere così impaurito
tolgo lat
e fu così vado dai medico mamma papà
guardate io ho paura non ce la faccio
più voglio togliere l'applicazione dal
web dagli store
i miei genitori mi dissero guarda se tu
sei felice così fallo fu la seconda
volta che fui molto imprudente
io con i miei genitori molto imprudente
perché da lì si iniziò a parlare molto
di più della vicenda in maniera molto
negativa quindi immaginate io e la mia
storia che partiamo da qui dominavamo il
mondo e dopo due settimane dominavamo
l'inferno se così si può dire io non
sapevo più cosa fare non studiavo più
perché poi mi iscrisse all'università o
meglio ne volevo la scusa per non
studiare più
non volevo saperne più dei miei amici
perché avevo paura che i miei amici
potessero chiedermi della vicenda
le uniche persone che frequentavo erano
i miei genitori e la mia ragazza che
erano le uniche persone che potevano
dirmi guarda se non hai fame e bevi la
camomilla almeno metti qualcosa nello
stomaco
da lì a un certo punto arriva una
notizia ancora più brutta
mi scrive questa multinazionale mi dice
complimenti hai vinto il premio dacci le
tue coordinate bancarie che ti inviamo i
100.000 dollari
io ero estasiato per me si era
totalmente cancellata la paura
peccato però che dopo due minuti arriva
un'altra email che dice ignora tutto
quello che ti abbiamo detto distrutto di
nuovo
allora li capite il sogno era svanito
perché dopo qualche settimana mi arriva
una mail finale che mi diceva guarda ci
dispiace ma non possiamo darti il premio
perché l'ato effettivamente va contro i
termini della piattaforma youtube
dall'inizio un percorso veramente
difficile a soli 19 anni non è molto
facile affrontare storie di questo tipo
e vi posso assicurare che poi per un
anno la mia vita è stata abbastanza
tremenda io non usavo più i cellulari
figuratevi non aprivo il computer il
laptop non riuscivo ad aprirlo avevo
paura di entrare e navigare su google e
trovare il mio nome trovare qualcuno che
parlasse della mia storia
ad un certo punto mia sorella che tra
l'altro fa la psicologa e meno male
decide di chiudermi in una stanza
portare un malloppo così di fogli che
erano articoli che parlavano di me tutti
sottolineati mi dice guarda tu leggi di
tutti non esci da qui se prima non hai
finito io non ne voglio sapere guarda
lasciamo perdere
no tu devi leggerli mi costrinse mi
costrinse perché lì capi per la prima
volta che gli articoli non parlavano
male di me personalmente come persona
come giovane come diciannovenne che
aveva creato qualcosa di incredibile ma
parlavano male di un po tutta la
situazione di quando fosse stato strano
tutto questo e allora lì basta
misi un punto incominciai a capire che
dovevo imparare continuare ad imparare
decisi di frequentare ambienti come
incubatori come acceleratori dove li
potevo imparare perché era solo questo
vi volevo conoscevo start up conoscevo
ragazzi imprenditori giovani mi
raccontavano le loro storie mi
imbarazzava ogni volta che mi
imbarazzava li capivo che stavo
imparando
dopo due anni di imbarazzo totale arriva
una piccola vocazione volevo portare
quello che avevo imparato e la mia
esperienza di totale fallimento nella
mia scuola dove che io ero cresciuto e
dove che io avevo imparato programmare
loro organizzo questo evento una due
giornate il primo giorno i ragazzi
dovevano capire cosa significava idea
start up e pitch una banale
presentazione da presentare agli
investitori per prendere del denaro e il
giorno dopo dovevano cimentarsi in una
competizione per esprimere se stessi
cosa vuol dire questo che i ragazzi
dovevano tirare fuori un idea mettere su
un team e lavorare alla presentazione da
presentare a dei giudici per vincere un
premio
doveva essere un solo evento
peccato però o forse per fortuna che
l'evento ebbe un successo incredibile in
italia perché fu considerato il primo
esperimento di educazione all
imprenditorialità giovanile mai avvenuto
in italia
fui chiamato da repubblica ad un evento
per parlare di questa storia fu nominato
uno dei venti giovani innovatori
italiani allora lì capii che
probabilmente l'impatto che creava
questa cosa che si chiama start up super
school doveva essere portato avanti
doveva essere coltivato
mi organizzai conobbi delle persone feci
un team e nel febbraio del 2016
lanciamo start up super school
ufficialmente in un anno abbiamo
coinvolto più di duemila alunni dai 16
ai 25 anni quindi scuole e università
siamo riusciti a stringere delle
sinergie con il ministero
dell'istruzione con la commissione
europea ecco le nazioni unite e adesso
per di più
stiamo anche andando all'estero stiamo
andando in croazia stiamo andando in
africa in messico ma la cosa che mi
piace di più quando racconto di questa
storia quando racconto di start up super
school è quello che ci sta dentro noi
andiamo nelle scuole insegniamo i
ragazzi ad essere non degli imprenditori
noi non vogliamo il ragazzino di 16 anni
a capo di un'impresa
noi vogliamo che pensi come un
imprenditore che è ben diverso
noi vogliamo che faccia sua la parola
responsabilità
noi vogliamo che si imbarazzi davanti a
chi può insegnare qualcosa io penso che
la cultura dell'imprenditorialità oggi
sia una delle chiavi più importanti
soprattutto tra i giovani perché possano
riuscire a capire che il fallimento e il
doversi imbarazzare davanti chi ha fatto
tanto e chi si è imbarazzato tanto e
continua ad imbarazzarsi sia tutto
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]